I I still like girls but um
I like boys too kit Connor one of the
stars of Netflix's amazing series Heart
Stopper was forced to come out as
bisexual after he was accused of
queerbaiting fans of the lgbtq Plus show
in the series kit stars as Nick a rugby
player who begins to question his
sexuality when he meets the openly gay
Charlie kit returned to Twitter for the
first time in seven weeks after taking a
break tweeting back for a minute I'm bi
congrats for forcing an 18 year old to
out himself I think some of you missed
the point of the show bye it's called
bisexuality
I wasn't born in the 18th century
look he's completely right some fans are
missing the point of the powerful series
which currently holds a perfect score of
a hundred percent on Rotten Tomatoes it
taught us many things but one of the
main takeaways should be that everyone
is on their own personal journey and
nobody should ever be forced to come out
now we're gonna tell people
yeah
[Music]
co-star Joe Locke voices support for Kit
replying you owe nothing to anyone I'm
so proud of you my friend Sebastian
Croft another Heart Stopper co-star
replied Conor the world doesn't deserve
you love you my friend and Alice oseman
who wrote the graphic novel on which the
series is based replied to Kitt's tweet
saying I truly don't understand how
people can watch Heart Stopper and then
gleefully spend their time speculating
about sexualities and judging based on
stereotypes I hope all those people are
embarrassed as F kit you are amazing now
this isn't the first time that kit has
had to take to Twitter after harassment
in May kit tweeted Twitter is so funny
man apparently some people on here know
my sexuality better than I do look
here's an idea and it's a simple one in
2022 we allow people to come out on
their own terms I hope you agree and
you'll be a positive force for these
actors who are sharing a beautiful queer
love story
[Laughter]